Det är ganska naturligt och jag skulle nog kunna, om det är något jag vill skicka med andra entreprenörer så är det att det är en jäkla fördel med att ha jobbat på något sätt med de som man grundar bolag med.
Man vet lite grann vad de går för då.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om det själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, kan du inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dessbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tvinga i ögonblicken.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Björn till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Tjena Björn.
Tjena då, tack för att jag får vara med i det här fenomenet Joel.
Exakt, du får med fenomenet entreprenörer inom e-handel.
Ni är ju större än de flesta bolagen som det skrivs om hela tiden, men jag tänker att ni säljer vitvaror.
Därför kanske inte det är lika sexigt att skriva om.
Kan det vara så kanske?
Ja, absolut.
Det är inte fashion eller beauty eller något av de spåren.
Vitvarorna är lite osexigare produkter, men ändå nånting som alla kommer i kontakt med någonstans under livet.
Vi är ju ett bolag som har ganska höga snittådda värden och då trycks omsättningen upp.
Vi ligger runt 250 miljoner ungefär om året.
Det är ändå hyggligt.
Ja, det är hyggligt.
Det blir 9 spänn i sekunden ungefär.
Vad snabb urräkning.
Det är ändå lite ball.
750 000 om dagen typ.
Det är kaxigt, snart miljoner.
Det var där vi låg 2023 åtminstone.
Du var med och grundade ett företag som heter Hemmy och sen har ni gått igenom en liten resa.
Vi börjar lite kort om bara Björn.
Kan du berätta lite för oss vem du är?
Jo, jag är egentligen en gammal programmerare och IT-utvecklare som tog mina staplande steg ut i näringslivet runt IT-bubblan och jobbade väldigt mycket med spännande IT-bolag då.
Sen tog jag steg mot projektledare roller och affärsutveckling och i slutändan landade jag inom e-handel och har jobbat både inom tekniska roller och även vd.
Vi grundade Hemmy 2018.
Det är den resan som jag har gjort rent karriärsmässigt.
Annars har jag fru och två barn och bor här i Stockholm.
Hyfsad amatörkock skulle jag säga.
Det är kort om mig.
Jag gillar det.
Är det vanligt att folk inom programmerar bakgrund blir vd?
Det känns inte som det vanligaste.
Nej, jag tror inte att det är det.
Det är oftast mer säljare bakgrund som är vanligare.
Men jag tror att det finns en grundläggande syn på att ett bolag är lite som ett system också.
På svår sätt kan man se att det finns olika rörliga delar som måste kunna matcha och få det att funka och flytta på.
Jag tror att det är det.
Jag är lite bredare än så.
Jag är inte heller den bästa programmeraren i världen.
Jag har nog en ganska bred profil på det sättet.
Men det var du som satt ihop er hemsida från start?
På Hemmy?
Ja, det var det.
Vi var fyra stycken grundare som startade Hemmy.
Vi hade lite olika bakgrund.
Det var inköpare och säljare.
Jag som hade den tekniska rollen.
Då var jag inte vd heller för Hemmy utan hade mer den lenordlade teknikrollen.
Jag körde på det spåret och byggde upp vår plattform.
Det var lite själv och samt med konsulter som vi tog in.
Då har du ändå hygglig kompetens inom att knäcka kod.
Jag kan få det att funka.
Ja, exakt.
Det är inte så att du bara kan dra block till en hemsida 24 sida.
Är du en av mycket få programmerare i Sverige som kan prata med andra människor?
Är det därför du blev vd?
Nej, det där är nog en myt skulle jag säga.
Är det verkligen en myt?
Det finns väl de riktigt inskränkta som bara sitter och tittar på datastrukturer hela dagen.
De flesta skarpa programmerare har ju extremt bra koll på hur man driver projekt och affärsutveckling.
Förstår affärsnyttan innan man börjar bygga någonting.
Jag tror att det är en gammal myt att det bara är det här mattesnillet som sitter i en garderob och knäcker kod.
Men visst.
Jag vill ju vara kvar i den här myten att det är så att de sitter i en garderob.
För annars har ju människor som är i ingen framtid i den här världen.
Vi som inte kan, vi som är helt tekniskt inkompetenta, vi blir utkonkurrerade annars.
Vi har ju bara att vi kan prata med människor.
Det är det enda vi har kvar.
Det är väl kanske en del som inte riktigt tycker det här med affärerna och kundsäljet som är det roligaste.
Att själva bygga systemet och bygga häftiga kundupplevelser är det ändå många som brinner för.
Den delen kan de gärna få vara med på tycker jag.
Jag tänker att om ni också har gjort en resa nu, vad sa du, 250 miljoner ungefär.
Det är ju väldigt väldigt fort.
Var det meningen att det skulle gå så fort?
Ja och nej, det skulle jag nog säga.
Som entreprenör och vd vill man ju ändå att det ska gå ännu fortare.
Man vill ju gärna ha mer hela tiden.
Men vi var ju ett gäng som jobbade på 30.se sedan tidigare.
Och där hoppade vi av för att vi såg att det fanns en liten nisch inom trädgård.
Där vi såg att vi hade ett gäng leverantörer som vi kunde jobba med.
Och ville bygga upp EMU som en renodlad trädgårds-site till en början.
Sen så av olika skäl, för att det var en stor aktör som lämnade Sverige så var det många vitvaruleverantörer som kom till oss och pratade med oss och gärna ville att vi skulle börja satsa på vitvaror.
Precis som vi hade gjort på 30.
Och då såg vi att det här fanns ju en fantastisk möjlighet nu att kunna återgå till det här som vi ändå har varit väldigt starka på sedan tidigare.
Och där vi hade uppodlade kontakter och så vidare.
Så den delen flöt vi naturligt tillbaka till.
Och när man bygger en vitvaruaffär så handlar det om volymer.
Det är egentligen det man alltid säger.
Det är ett volymspel.
Det vill säga att du kommer inte åt de riktigt bra inköpspriserna och så där innan du kommer upp i riktigt stora volymer där du kan beställa containers av vitvaror från olika typer av fabriker framförallt runtom i Europa.
Men det är egentligen därför vi behövde kunna växa så snabbt som vi gjorde också.
Och gick med underskott lite grand de första åren och så där.
Så det är lite grand där som affären har funnits när man bygger upp det på det sättet.
Så att ja, det behöver kunna gå så fort.
Annars så kommer man bli uppäten av sina egna kostnader.
Och samtidigt som man gör det här så gäller det att hålla ett otroligt slimmat bolag och inte springa runt och anställa för mycket folk eller investera för mycket i teknik och andra typer av satsningar som inte lönar sig på kort sikt.
Men vad för övrigt är Hemmi?
Ett jävligt bra namn på ett trädgårdsbolag.
Eller du vet, jag gillar namnet Hemmi.
Det passar väldigt bra för det ni tänkte att det skulle vara.
Hade ni hunnit köpa in ett trädgårdsprodukt och lägga upp hela den grejen eller kom pivoten såpass tidigt att ni kunde styra om direkt?
Det kom relativt tidigt.
Men sen vi har haft trädgårdsfotumentet också hela tiden.
Då gjorde vi mycket grillar och gräsklippar och sådana saker.
Men Vitevarna har definitivt seglat upp och blivit en stor del av det som vi gör.
Och vi valde namnet Hemmi för att kunna fylla det med lite vad som helst också.
Även om vi började inom trädgård och sådär så skulle vi kunna gå vidare inom Hemmi-redning eller vad som helst.
Det var nog ett av hundra eller hundrafemtio olika namn som vi satt och tittade på och kollade allt ifrån morgmärkesregisteringar till lediga domännamn och allt möjligt.
Vad var det sämsta namnet ni hade?
Oj, det fanns så många dåliga.
Björn Fanto-gänget.
Exakt, den var inte där.
Men någonstans i liknande ballpark skulle jag säga att vi hittade några namn.
Ni var fyra stycken grundare och allihopa kom från 30?
Ja, exakt.
Vi var fyra grundare varav en inte var operativ som bara investerare.
Hur är det när man startar ett bolag inom en bransch som man redan har jobbat inom?
Blir det lite känsligt eller är det vanligt?
Hur sker det där?
Det är klart att det kan vara intresse från både leverantörer och gamla kolleger och sådana saker.
Definitivt.
Men generellt skulle jag säga att det är mindre kontroversiellt än man tror.
Vi gillar e-handel och vi gillar att bygga upp det här.
Även gamla kollegor på 30 och sånt där, de ligger upp naturligt på LinkedIn.
Det är klart att man ger dem en like när de lyckas med någonting.
Men ändå i samma våt på något sätt.
Vi vill försöka få kunderna till att e-handla så mycket som möjligt.
Jag tror snarare att vi hjälper varandra på det sättet.
Men jag tror att det kan finnas både en fördel och en nackdel att agera inom samma bransch.
En annan av de stora fördelarna är att man vet precis vad man ger sig in på.
Man vet exakt var någonstans man ska sälja sina saker, vilka produkter man ska prata om, vilka marginaler man ska räkna med och hur branschen fungerar.
Det är många misstag som man slipper göra när man startar bolaget.
Har ni fyra en passion för...
Nu tänkte ni gå in genom trädgården.
Men älskar du tvättmaskiner?
Jag älskar inte tvättmaskiner, men mina kollegor gjorde det.
Absolut.
Vi har bland de bästa vitvarunördarna i hela Sverige, skulle jag säga, som kan allt ifrån vilka typer av motorer som finns i torktumlarna till de senaste funktionerna som kommer från Smartahemmet.
Så där har vi riktigt bra folk.
Och det underlättar ju också.
Hur drar man igång?
Du nämnde ju att man behöver komma upp i volym ganska snabbt.
Ni behöver också ha en lagersetup som är ganska rejäl redan från start.
Eftersom vi säljer gymutrustning så vet jag ju hur det är att ha volym.
Det är inte så att ni får in tre pall, utan ska ni köpa in en modell så är det ju 20 pall bara i sig.
Det binder ju volym ganska fort och ni ska få ut, så det är mycket lastbilar som ska komma in och ut.
En reklamation är en stor grej.
Hur gör man den setupen?
Ni måste ha haft en del kapital, ni måste ha förberett detta en del.
Men du sa att ni gjorde en pivot snabbt till vitvaror, så det måste ändå gått lite hetsigt.
Jag är bara fascinerad av hur ni drog igång.
Fördelen med de stora vitvarorleverantörerna är att du behöver inte ha allting i lager.
Det är relativt enkelt att kunna få tag på leveranser av två, fyra eller sex tvättmaskiner, till exempel från en modell bara på några dagar.
Det här var ju innan de störde leveranskedjorna under covid.
Men det här har ju rättat upp sig igen.
Så det är ju ändå en fördel, så du behöver inte ha allting i lager från start.
Men vi valde ju ändå att ha ett lager och inte dropshippa eller någonting sånt där, vilket också finns.
Men då är det ju helt andra prisbilder också.
Men vi har ett lager ända sedan start, där vi har tagit in det som vi vet säljer och som fungerar på den svenska marknaden.
Och vi vet också att lager fördar varor och säljer enklare och snabbare.
Och speciellt när man kan få snabb leverans.
Alltså går din frys sönder så vill du ha en ny inom gärna två dagar, gärna en dag.
Så därigenom valde vi ut det sortimentet som vi tyckte var viktigast.
Sen så vet jag också att du kan antingen lägga pengarna på att ha lager och ha en bra lagerprocess och ha bra kontroll över dina leveranser.
Eller så kan du ju försöka samordna allting från en massa olika leveranser och försöka cross-docka det på något ställe.
Men då kan det lättare bli så att det springer iväg i kostnader kring kundservice.
För då har du inte samma kontroll på hela leveranskedjan gentemot slutkunden.
För det blir alldeles många in-
och utleveranser att hålla reda på på en gång.
Så det är ju lättare att köpa in dem i bulk så mycket som möjligt.
När man hör såna här stora säljare så står de ju där.
Sen så klart att de bindt kapital så du måste ju vara ganska noggrann med vilka produkter som du ställer i lager, helt klart.
Hur mycket kapital hade ni i början?
Vi hade bara några miljoner som vi hade tagit in så det var inte jättemycket.
Så där var vi verkligen snåla med det vi gjorde och jobbade ut alla lön och sådana saker första tiden.
Det är klart att det var tajt och knapert men när man ser att det växer och slutmålet finns någonstans där vid horisonten så är det ändå jäkligt motiverande och väldigt kul.
Hur stort var det första lagret ni gick in i?
1500 kvadratmeter.
Oj det är ändå en ganska kaxig...
Sen är inte det så stort med tanke på vad som sen hände.
Men jag menar det är inte många som börjar med en lagerita på 1500 kvadratmeter.
Det behövs ju när man ställer saker på fall.
Det tar lätt plats.
Jag vill tänka mig att vitvaror är en extremt jämförelsesstyrd bransch.
Det är ganska enkelt att googla eller prisjakta sig fram och se vad som finns.
Men ni måste ju ändå ha sett att här finns någon sorts lucka.
Vad var det för lucka eller vad är det som inte är gjort?
Det som vi såg, dels för att vi har jobbat på 30 sen tidigare men har ju även koll på branschen och marknaden så ser vi att det fortfarande finns en möjlighet att kunna komma in på den här marknaden.
Både med pris men också framförallt med...
Det låter ju lite klichert att med ett bättre kunderbjudande.
Men det var lite det det handlade om.
Jag har aldrig hört den här meningen förut.
Nej.
Vi ville ha ett extremt slimmat bolag så att vi skulle kunna hålla låga priser och konkurrera med våra konkurrenter.
Det skulle jag säga att vi lyckades med.
Men sen så mäter vi oss extremt mycket på våra kundbetyg på Trustbidet och Prisakt och Pricerunner.
Det är vår benchmark och vi är några av de viktigaste kopierna att läsa lite om vilka reviews vi får och vad är det som de har problem med.
Är det mycket till leveranserna till exempel så tar vi tag i det.
Då ser vi till att emballera produkterna på ett annat sätt, spänna fast dem på pallar, prata med våra speditörer.
Så hela den biten.
Sen även lite stödet kring en massa automatiserade kommunikationsmöjligheter med mina sidor och sådana här andra saker.
Som man idag kanske tar lite för givet men ändå som är information till kunden hela tiden.
Så här går det med din leverans just nu och den kommer komma den här och den här tiden.
Då får du komma ihåg att förbereda ditt hem för att de som bär in dig i ditt hem behöver ha skorna på sig.
Så mycket sådana där saker som både undviker kundservicessamtal för oss men också gör att betygen på alla de här betygssajterna klättrar.
Så det har varit vår nisch skulle jag kunna säga.
Vi lägger inte ut en massa pengar på brandmarketing eller något liknande sådant där utan det handlar om att göra jobbet i alla delar.
Jag tänker att det är viktigare än vad man kan tänka.
Om man sitter och lyssnar på detta så tänker man att alla är noga med leveransen.
Men får du en dubbelkyl på 250 kilo som bara går in på sexkärra och du behöver ha någon som faktiskt inte är rädd för att köra in den.
Så är ju det en liten process.
Det är ju inte bara väska.
Har ni även folk som monterar och servar ut och hämtar i gamla och löser ni även sådant?
Ja absolut det har vi.
Vi jobbar med flera olika firmor runtom i Sverige så vi har ett heltäckande erbjudande för att både kunna bära in som du säger de väger ju ganska mycket de här.
Men även att kunna installera och ta med sig de gamla Strasja maskinerna och skicka dem på återvinning.
Så vi tycker att vi har ett heltäckande lösning där.
Hur ser ni till att jobba med, för de blir ju på något sätt era ambassadörer, men av erfarenhet så är ju inte alla i den branschen asköna utan det finns ju folk som går in med leriga skor och tycker att det här är mitt jobb typ.
Hur håller ni koll på det där?
Nej men en del, vad kul att du har jobbat med det förresten, det hade jag ingen aning om.
Ja verkligen, men det är precis som du säger det är klart att det finns rötag inom alla branscher och så.
Vi har ju en del partners som jobbar med många underleverantörer helt enkelt och de har ju det ansvarigt och skyldigheten att mäta och följa upp allting.
Och det skickas ju ut sådana här MPS-lös uppföljningar kring vad kunderna tycker om leveranserna och även tilläggstjänsterna som installation och så där.
Så det följer vi upp noga och i Stockholm framförallt så jobbar vi med en partner där vi följer själva väldigt noga hela tiden.
Och pratar med dem och har deras historier och träffar deras installatörer och får även en del bilder och filmer och sådant som har skickats kring vad som görs.
Det finns mycket som kan gå fel men det är också extremt mycket som går rätt.
Jag tänker också det, är det en duktig installatör eller en skön människa som är ut, då lyfter ju det hela er att varumärke.
Då blir ju det liksom en superkänsla av det.
Men som sagt det kan ju gå fruktansvärt fel.
Ja visst, är det jag skulle nog säga att det är nog den viktigaste delen av våra kundbetyg.
Det är själva leveransen ut till det kunde.
Att det går snabbt och att det inte blir några problem på vägen.
Det är där man ser om det är någonting som sänker betygen så är det oftast där.
När ni fyra gick ihop och startade hem var det så, det lät som att ni var en av varje sort.
Om du förstår vad jag menar.
En inköpare, en marknadsför.
Var det meningen att det skulle vara så eller bara råkade det bli så?
Fanns det någon femte person som ville vara med men som var lite sämre programmerare än dig så han fick inte vara med?
Nej det var det.
Vi pratade nog ihop oss egentligen bara och så landade vi i det.
Vi kom väldigt bra överens på bolaget på 30 sen tidigare och det blev ganska naturligt.
Om det är något som jag vill skicka med andra entreprenörer så är det att det är en jäkla fördel med att ha jobbat på något sätt med de som man grundar bolag med.
Man vet lite grann vad de går för då.
Det är någonting i hur hårt de jobbar, vilka kunskaper de har, vilka kvaliteter de har.
Hur fungerar det med allt från leverantör till kunder.
Så det finns många sådana saker.
Jag har startat flera bolag förut också tillsammans med andra konstellationer, både folk som jag har jobbat med och inte jobbat med.
Det skulle jag säga är en nyckel.
Det behöver inte vara att man har varit anställdare på samma ställe.
Men bara att man har gjort någon typ av projekt eller något lite tillsammans.
Då lär man känna varandra ganska bra och då förstår man.
Det är ju lite som att gifta sig med någon.
Man spenderar ju extremt mycket tid med de här medgrunderna.
Man behöver inte vara överens hela tiden, men det gäller att man kan jobba tillsammans och bygga bolag tillsammans.
Bråka schysst.
Är det fortfarande ni fyra som är kvar?
Vi är bara två stycken kvar som jobbar operativt i bolaget nu.
Det är ingen kontrovers eller något.
Det är bara naturligt att det blir så till slut.
Som sagt, ni har startat 2018.
Dels har ni vuxit väldigt fort och dels har det varit corona och lågkonjunktur.
Ni har också blivit uppköpta, delvis eller helt.
Det har hänt ganska mycket.
Kan du inte ta oss lite genom the storyline?
Absolut.
2018 grundade vi Hemby och körde på den under ganska lång tid.
Vi hade corona och hela den delen som spökade till för alla vi e-handlare.
Det var fantastisk försäljning i början och sen ett platt fall för de flesta.
Men vi byggde vidare på vår affär under alla de här åren och växte stadigt hela tiden.
Vi såg till att investera varenda liten krona i vinst i att köpa in mer och mer tillager så att vi växte, växte och växte.
Det var tillväxt som var det stora fokuset under de här åren för alla.
Alla ville fortsätta ta en större del av kakan.
I början av 2022 pratade vi med vitvaruexperten som kom till oss och började prata och sa något otroligt smart.
Vi är två vitvarubolag.
En ligger i södra Stockholm och en ligger i norra Stockholm.
Därför ska vi inte slå våra påsar ihop.
Det var helt otroligt bra och det blev ännu bättre när vi började titta på våra två affärer.
Vilka leverantörer vi jobbade med, var vi starka och svaga.
Det var en otroligt bra match.
Det var där vi beslutade oss för att gå ihop.
Vitvaruexperten är ägda av BHG Group sen tidigare.
Den här affären blev ett förvärv av BHG Group med syfte att slå ihop de här två verksamheterna.
Det är egentligen det som har hänt sen 2022.
Sen dess har vi jobbat på att få ihop de två bolagen och landat i det nu.
Nu är vi funktionerat till ett bolag.
Vitvaruexperten finns kvar som bolag.
Både hemi.se och vitvaruexperten.com finns kvar som två olika sajter med ganska lika erbjudanden.
Hem är fortfarande en bredare sajt.
På vitvaruexperten fokuserar vi mer på just det här experterbjudandet.
Kring vitvarorna, med paketeringen och alla vitvaror för hela köket och hela hemmet.
Det har landat väldigt väl.
Men det var hemi som var större än vitvaruexperten?
Nej, vitvaruexperten var större än hemi.
Det kommer se också i att alla vitvarorna som säljs på exempelvis bygghemma.se säljs via vitvaruexperten.
Det är en större affär.
BHG Group är ju en jättegrupp med massor av e-handlare.
Bygghemma.se är väl den största sajten.
Men det finns ju många andra sajter där också.
Nordic Nest och många, många hyra.
Jag fattar.
Men det var ändå en vd från hemi som fick hoppa upp och ta vd-rollen på det kombinerade bolaget här till slut?
Ja, det var inte självklart för början.
Men det är det vi är nu.
Sen ett år tillbaka är jag vd för vitvaruexpertenbolaget.
Hur gör man?
För folk pratar ju alltid om att för horner låter fint på papper och sådär, men att det blir skit i verkligheten.
Hur gör man för att det faktiskt ska bli bra?
Du sa att det har gått bra nu.
Så vad gjorde ni som faktiskt blev bra?
Jag tror att det gäller att både springa snabbt och långsamt skulle jag säga.
Det finns ju massor.
Men då så.
Vi släpper det där.
Exakt, väldigt tydligt.
Det finns massor av små praktiska saker som man snabbt kan lösa.
Man kan byta kreditgivare och lösa smarta saker som bara förbättrar likviditet.
Man kan få ihop bolagen rent mätmässigt.
Man sätter upp samma gemensamma nyckeltal och sådana saker.
Det går ganska snabbt.
Sen så finns det saker och ting som behöver ta lite längre tid.
Det är att kunna slå ihop lager, till exempel.
Att man inte gör det i en snabb rörelse utan det.
Där finns det ju kontrakt och allt möjligt att ta hänsyn till.
Så där finns det massor av sådana saker.
Inget av våra två lager var tillräckligt stort för att hålla båda bolagen.
Vi har flyttat till ett gemensamt större lager exempelvis.
Sådana där analyser måste man ju kunna få göra.
Samtidigt ska man titta på helheten i vad vi är någonstans och vad vi ska ta vägen tillsammans.
Så det skulle jag nog säga är en nyckel.
Samma sak med teknik.
Där ska man inte heller bara springa in och hoppa på den ena eller den andra lösningen.
Utan verkligen försöka göra hemläxande och se vad det är för något som är bra och dåligt med båda.
Så ska man såklart kunna ta alla de svåra besluten också och se att nu måste vi kunna jobba på samma sätt på kundtjänst.
Vi kan inte ha två olika ticketsystem och sådana saker utan vi måste försöka få in alla så att vi kan underlätta för varandra.
För det finns ingen poäng i att vi sitter och svarar på exakt samma frågor fast i två helt olika processer och system.
Så mycket sådana där saker kommer naturligt men dels en plan över snabba saker som behöver ske de första 90 dagarna.
Och sen så är det en massa förändringsprojekt som behöver komma på vägen.
När två bolag går ihop så här, hur upplever du att personalen tycker att det är?
Tycker de att blev de glada när ni skulle gå ihop eller blev de mer fan?
Nu skiter det sig.
Jag tror att det beror väldigt mycket på vilken typ av person man är.
En del älskar förändring och en del hatar förändring.
Så det är absolut blandade känslor och hos en del personer blir det mycket vi och de tänker.
Så därför tror jag att det är ännu viktigare att man i ledningen är ganska tydlig med vad man vill någonstans tillsammans.
Så att man på något sätt kommunicerar att det är det här som är det nya bolaget.
Det är två grupper av människor som är vana att jobba på olika sätt.
Även om vi har jobbat inom samma bransch och med nästan samma produkter och så vidare.
Så är det förvånansvärt hur olika man kan jobba egentligen på olika delar.
Så det gäller att kunna vara lyhörd för det där samtidigt som man ser till och sätter riktningen så att alla förstår vart vi är på väg skulle jag säga.
Men är det samma om vi tar kundtjänst till exempel.
Jobbar hem i kundtjänsten också med vitvarurexperten.
Kundtjänst eller är det fortfarande två?
Nej, nej.
Idag är det ett team.
Absolut.
Jag tänkte säga annars blir det nästan lite vi och dem i alla fall.
Bara per automatik.
Ja, absolut.
Det är ett team som jobbar och man ser ju från vilken sajt som kunderna ringer och mailar och så svarar man utifrån det så att säga.
Är ni kvar som ägare i någonting idag eller är ni bara anställda idag?
Vi har en liten minoritetsägareandel kvar fortfarande och det är ganska vanligt i sådana här konstellationer när man köper upp bolagen så att säga.
Man har kvar lite möjlighet för ägaren att finnas kvar under ett gäng år till för att kunna växa den sista lilla andelen så att säga.
Så vi sålde en del i samband med försäljningen och sen ligger vi kvar med en liten del kvar.
Jag hade ett intalsnitt här med Joel på Partykungen och han berättade att det var lite konstigt när de blev uppköpta.
Han kände att han tappade lite motivation i att jobba när han blev anställd snarare än var ägare.
Kan ni uppleva samma sak eller kan du uppleva samma sak?
Nej, jag tror inte det.
Jag kan förstå det verkligen.
Definitivt.
Jag är ju entreprenör i grund och botten också och i entreprenörskapet ligger det ganska mycket i att kunna få bestämma allting själv och få sätta sin egen resa.
Nu tar man ju hänsyn till en större kontext, absolut.
Men för mig är resan ändå det viktigaste och så länge jag ser att det här är en kul resa som vi fortsätter på så spelar inte det så jättestor roll för mig.
Om jag är anställd eller inte.
Det är kul att bygga saker på skala och ju större de blir desto roligare blir det på något sätt.
Är det det du drivs av?
Inte att det är ditt som växer utan snarare att det växer?
Till viss del är det absolut kul när det är mitt som växer också.
Jag gick runt och tittade på laget i början där och sa att de här är mina.
En liten del av de som står här för de här pallen är mina, det är jag som ansvarar för att de här ska säljas någonstans.
Det kanske man inte gör lika mycket nu längre.
Men det är klart att det finns en liten aspekt av det där.
Men jag tror snarare att själva resan och att vi faktiskt gör någonting som är så otroligt kul just nu.
Det är värt mer just nu än just den ägardelen skulle jag säga.
Går ni runt och tänker, jag tänker att när ni var på 30 då var ju ni ett litet gäng liksom som funderade på nu ska vi komma härifrån, nu gör vi någonting bättre och så bygger vi upp det.
Blir du lite protectionistisk nu och går runt och lyssnar på dina kollegor när de snackar lite grann och så tänker du att ingen får smita härifrån nu, jag ska vara först med att ta alla goda idéer.
Hur gör ni för att bibehålla personalen så att alla entreprenörer stannar kvar i bolaget och jobbar i bolaget och inte försvinner?
Oj, det där är en jättebra fråga.
Jag tror att jag är lite delad där.
Dels så skulle jag nog, om någon skulle hoppa av vårt bolag och att det här varit en platskola för att kunna bygga nästa hundra miljoners bolag inom e-handel, då hade jag varit ganska stolt.
Nej, nej Björn, nej, nej, då hade du ringt våra kontakter.
Jag vet att du blir fruförbannad men jag är den andra typen.
Varför är alla jag intervjuar så jävla trevliga, fan finns det inget hat i den här världen.
Men sen med det sagt, det finns vissa nykkelpersoner på bolaget och alla bolag som man jobbar på som är sådär, den här personen kommer vi inte klara oss utan liksom.
Och det gäller ju bara att försöka motivera de personerna så gott det går.
Jag har ingen silver bullet för exakt hur man gör det.
Men jag tror att så länge man på något sätt lyckas visa att resandet i världen var med på så hoppas jag att de stannar kvar då.
Men om vi tar er då, vad var det som fick er att faktiskt vilja lämna?
Vad var det ni saknade?
Vad var det ni var liksom?
Någonstans tog ni ju steget?
Ja absolut.
Dels var det ju den här marknadsöppningen då lite grann inom Taggart som vi såg.
Och sen så var det ju även att vi ville bygga ett bolag där vi dels ville förenkla allting.
Alltså vi skulle ha liksom, det skulle vara superenkelt att göra allting från svar på kundtjänstmail till att pimma produkter, till att skicka produkter och så vidare.
Vi skulle ha ett enkelt bolag att driva utan en massa komplicerade resurser med att testa blocker och allt möjligt.
Så det var väl en del av det själva bolagsbyggandet som vi såg.
Men sen så var det...
Vi måste ju säga, vi måste ju givetvis komma i frågan, har ni byggt det bolaget idag?
Ja det har vi.
Alltså, ja vad skönt.
Vad var det sista där du sa sen?
Men sen så var det det här som jag var inne på tidigare med kommunikationen.
Som skulle kunna vara helt oöverträffad på alla nivåer som vi vill kunna göra.
Det är det viktigaste.
Vem är det som står för den värderingen skulle du säga?
För att det är ju ganska vanligt när företag blir uppköpta på det här sättet att omdömerna bara faller.
Alltså att man på något sätt matas in i någon struktur och så blir man rätt kast på just...
Ja men kundservice och faktiskt ta hand om kunder, det blir väldigt centraliserat.
Det blir bara väldigt dåligt.
Men ni har ju faktiskt bibehållt nöjda kunder och liknande.
Hur?
Det är också en bra fråga men jag tror att det är...
Jag tror att vi är rätt många i bolaget som ändå har koll på allt.
Alltså jag har en lagchef som är helt magisk.
Som verkligen bryr sig om att grejerna kommer fram hela och rena till kunderna.
Jag har liksom en inköpschef som ser till att vi har liksom helt rätt priser hela tiden.
För våra kunder och är med och skapar kampanjer och alla sådana här saker.
Liksom verkligen nere örat mot rälsen.
Och sen så har vi kundtjänsteam som är verkligen empatiska och lyssnar in och kollar vad är det faktiskt som är problemet här så att säga.
Och håller hela den här spindeln i nätet.
Diskussionerna tillsammans med späddigtörer och leverantörer och kunder och allting.
Alltså det blir många olika delar.
Men generellt sett så sitter det i människorna och det behöver nog finnas i alla avdelningar på något sätt.
Inte minst vi som sitter i lite ledningsfunktion.
Vill du säga att ni har rekryterat sådana människor och hur letar ni efter det i så fall eller har ni bara haft lite tur?
Vi har nog inte rekryterat efter de premisserna skulle jag säga.
Utan vi har nog bara sett till att rätt människor har fått möjligheten att växa inom bolaget.
Om vi snackar lite om er marginal.
Om man lyssnar på E-Anders poddar så tycker jag alltid att de säger att man ska ha en marginal någonstans runt 60, 70, 80 procent i bästa fall.
Och då sitter jag och tänker, kan inte alla hålla käften, det är ju inte den marginalen vi andra har.
Och sen så tänker jag att när jag pratar om min marginal här, vi hade ett dåligt år på 40 någonting procent, 45.
Då tänker du, kan inte Joel hålla käften för där fick jag inte.
För ni ihop med teknikvaror ligger ju på en helt annan marginal.
Ni ligger ju kanske någonstans mellan 10-20 procent.
Ja, absolut.
Det är svårt för andra bolag att ens tänka sig hur man går runt eller hur man ens hanterar det och löser det.
Absolut.
Jag förstår helt av den tanken och att ligga på 70-80 procent skulle vara helt magiskt.
Och det är väl lite så här återigen det här med att när man bygger en vitvarufär så är det en volymaffär.
Så att det är ju större man blir desto bättre marginaler får man.
Och det är ju, det är ju inte nere på de marginalerna som är mobiltelefoner och tv-operatorer och sådana saker och datorer.
Det är ju verkligen där det finns noll pengar kvar så att säga.
Så vi har ju en lite sundare affär än så skulle jag ändå säga och har ju vuxit väldigt mycket.
Så nu tycker jag att vi har en väldigt sund affär.
Men det det det handlar om ändå, det jag gillar egentligen med de här riktiga lågmarginalbranscherna det är ju att man måste verkligen gå ner i detaljerna.
Alltså det är varenda liten, alltså varenda kontrakt med speletörer spelar roll.
Varenda krona du spenderar på marketing spelar roll och varenda lagerkostnad eller pallplats spelar roll.
Så att du behöver hålla en örnkoll på verkligen ner i detaljerna kring allting.
Och det tror jag bygger en sund affär.
Vi tackar in dig till egentligen all typ av social media marketing och sånt där.
För att det finns liksom ingen, det finns ingen typ av affär för oss att hämta där.
Vi måste hålla oss i de här riktigt slimade performance marketing kanalerna och det är där vi ser att det verkligen verkligen funkar.
Så att det är, jag tror att det är där det handlar.
Det handlar om alla affärer går att driva om man bara gör det på rätt sätt.
Det kanske saknar väl att ju mer vinst man gör desto snabbare kan man ju fortsätta bygga bolaget och bygga ut större lager och kanske expandera till fler kategorier.
Men det är också många bolag som kanske blir lite bortskämda med höga marginaler och börjar kasta bort pengar på en massa konstiga projekt som inte skapar någon typ av affärsvärde huvudtaget.
Och då har man ju ett problem i sig som kanske är svårare att hantera än att man behöver förhandla om ett politörsavtal till exempel.
Jag tänker att vi ska snacka lite grann om det, men varför är just vitvaror så pressade?
Är det för att det bara är en massa varumärken där och det stora inköp om man kan jämföra?
För det finns ju många andra affärer som också är jämförelsebara, men ni har av någon anledning hamnat i det.
Ligger man vaken och tänker på det och är sur liksom?
Nej, men jag tror att det kommer naturligt från all elektronik och att det som finns på price-runner och prisrätt det är ju primärt elektronikvaror som folk jämför.
Det är ju svårare att jämföra pris på en soffa och så vidare och det kanske är lite mer av ett livsstilsval än att köpa en ny tvättmaskin.
Sen med det sagt så är det ju mer och mer som är viktigt för hemmet när det gäller även vitvaror.
Att du får en matchande kyl och frys och kanske en matchande mikro och ung till exempel eller även matchande tvättmaskin och torktubblare även om de kanske inte syns någonstans i hemmet förutom i tvättstugan.
Så det finns ju många olika delar där som gör att man även inte behöver konkurrera på pris.
Men det är primärt en sån här sällanköpsvaror precis som datorer och TV-apparater och sådant där så därför kommer vi in under en kategori skulle jag säga.
Är det så att man accepterar att det är så världen ser ut?
Vi kommer ha en marginal som ligger mellan det här spannet och därför jobbar vi typ 95% med processerna och andra sidan eller sitter ni och jobbar med projekt som ska kunna skapa produkter som inte prispressas?
Det gör vi.
Men jag tror att vi håller också på att bygga ut hela kundhjälpbjudandet med ytterligare tilläggstjänster och andra typer av kundhjälpbjudanden som vi vet att vi kan ta betalt för.
Som vadå till exempel?
Det kan ju vara allt möjligt.
En lite mindre satsning som vi har gjort är att vi jobbar tillsammans med bolaget Skärgårdar för att göra leveranser ut i Stockholms skärgård.
De leveranserna kostar ju flera tusen kronor men de kunderna som bor därut är ju villiga att betala för det.
Så det är inte heller någonting som gör en make it or break it för vår affär men det är många sådana där detaljer som gör att hela vår kundhjälpbjudandet blir bättre men även affären blir sundare.
När ni jobbar med...
Jag bara förutsätter att ni inte har drivfrakt och liknande sådana.
Har ni betalt för den riktiga frakten mot kunden eller subventionerar ni?
Hur jobbar ni?
Vi är subventioneraren.
Vi skulle inte kunna ta betalt för hela frakten för det gör inte våra konkurrenter också.
Så vi ligger väldigt bra i fraktpris och gentemot fler konkurrenter och det kan vara också väldigt viktigt i många fall.
Men vi subventionerar absolut frakten men det blir fortfarande en sundare affär än vad den var för tio år.
När alla skulle ha fri frakt...
Har man massor av sådana express-alternativ där ni kan få tillbaka en större del av frakten eller medmontering?
Jag tänker om ni pushar sådana tjänster.
Jag är bara helt fascinerad över hur man jobbar med den här marginalen.
Vi har testat väldigt mycket och express är förvånansvärt få som väljer att betala extra för.
Det tror man inte om frysen går sönder.
Men det är förvånansvärt få som valde det.
Så det är absolut de andra typerna av värdeskapande tjänsterna som installation och sånt där som vi fokuserar på.
Men även möjlighet att kunna välja leveransdag och tid och sådana där fönster.
Det är sådana där chock som vi håller på att titta på hela tiden.
När du pratar om att vi förhandlar om avtal eller vi inne och kollar på att det finns pallplatser till exakt den grejen.
Ni är lite nördiga eller nere på detaljnivå.
Men finns det någonting som du tror att andra företag som har 60 procent marginal kan lära sig av er som inte är bara att kolla på detaljerna?
Finns det några konkreta grejer som det här verkar de här vara så jävla kass på?
Ja, bra fråga.
Det minsta man kan göra är att förhandla om sina avtal.
Det är samma sak med dispeditörer och betalningsläventörer.
Det handlar om att mäta sin marketing.
Ska man lägga 10 procent i marketing eller 8 procent i marketing?
Det kanske ger exakt samma resultat.
Jag tror att man måste orka ta sig tiden för det.
Det är många sådana saker.
Du nämner att det här är ett sådant numbers game, alltså volym, bygger affären och man får bättre priser och det gör ju också att saker blir mer logiska på något sätt.
Här är ju de rörliga kostnaderna.
Det är det viktigaste.
Varenda grej som verkligen bekostar varje order du skickar ut.
Det är där man måste ha den bästa kontrollen.
De andra delarna kommer naturligt till i andra diskussioner.
Men det här är ju sådant som man kan följa upp varje månad och försöka göra någonting åt.
Men kommer er bransch bli en enda aktör i Sverige till slut?
Bitarbranschen?
Nej, det tror jag verkligen inte.
Vem ska kunna komma in och konkurrera om sådär fem år?
Som ny aktör.
Det är svårare att slå sig in.
Det är det absolut.
Men jag tror att det är varken kunder eller leverantörer som vill ha en enda stor aktör.
Leverantörerna vill gärna att vi har flera olika som ändå kan så att det inte blir en stor leverantör på marknaden som dikterar alla villkor.
Och sen så kommer kunderna ändå alltid behöva den här typen av specialister.
För att bli det en enda stor aktör så kommer den aktören inte heller bara sälja vitvaror.
Det vill säga att den kommer att ha ett lite spretigare sortiment och då så kommer den inte heller vara specialist på just vitvaror och kanske inte vara specialist på de här kundomötanden där man gör de här leveranserna och installationerna och så vidare.
Det finns absolut bra aktörer, stora aktörer därute redan nu men det kommer inte bli bara en.
Men jag tänker så som Byggehemmagruppen jobbar till exempel då blir ju ni en tentakel i det bygget och då kan ni vara specialister på detta men ni kan ändå jobba med centraliserade lager eller kreditförhandlingar eller vad det var ni skulle kunna vara.
Jag bara tänker att om sådär 10-15 år i en bransch som inte tar fram egna varumärken, som inte jobbar med egna produktioner så till slut måste det bara vara en enda stor som bara tar hand om det.
Are we doomed?
Vi får se vem som har rätt.
Jag tror att det alltid kommer finnas möjligheter för kreativa entreprenörer att komma in och disrupta branscher på något sätt.
Om det är någonting jag är rädd för, jag som har fyllt 45 så är det väl lite så här att de som är 27 år idag de föddes i år 2000 eller 24 år idag menar jag såklart.
De var ju sju år gamla när de fick sin första iPhone eller när iPhone släpptes, så mobilen är ju det de har vuxit upp med.
Så där har vi en jättereis att göra.
Det går inte bara att bygga en website längre och hoppas på att man kan sälja lite Google Ads och hoppas på att det kommer gå bra utan det kommer vara ett helt annat liv som kvetsar kring helt andra typer av digitala upplevelser där det måste kunna finnas ett sätt att kunna passa in som vi inte gör idag.
Jag tänker alltid att fördelen med att jobba i branscher som är osäksiga typ avfall, vitvaror och i mitt fall gymutrustning att det är en tråkig bransch att starta i.
Det kräver lager, det kräver logistik och det går lite långsamt i början.
Det är ingen som vill jobba med rätt.
Vi klarar oss kanske.
Jag tror också att en fördel är att både du och jag är ganska duktiga på att skicka saker på pall och hantera palllager.
Det är inget automatiserat robotlager eller något sånt där som kan konkurrera ut det.
Sen måste man vara jäkligt vass på att vara just palllager.
Men det finns en liten tröskel där att ta sig över.
Jag tänkte bara prata lite kort också om sortimentet.
Du nämnde det lite själv här med att kunderna kanske vill ha en specialist.
Samtidigt är ni ganska breda och du nämnde även grillar och liknande här.
Vart går gränsen?
Hur man ska göra?
Bra fråga.
Hur bred ska ni bli?
När börjar man?
Och inget ont om biltema.
Jag åker själv till biltema.
Men till slut blir man ett biltema där man hämtar allting.
Vart drar ni gränsen?
Jag skulle säga att vi har varit för spretiga definitivt.
Vi har ju sålt alltifrån TV-apparater och leksaker till grillar och vitvaror och sådana saker.
Det blir ganska naturligt när man börjar jobba med fler och fler leverantörer.
De har ett större erbjudande.
Man har mycket fokus på tillväxt.
Det gäller den gamla sanningen att ju fler produkter som man lägger upp på sajten desto mer säljer man.
Och till viss del är det sant och till stor del är det inte sant.
När börjar det bli inte sant?
Någonstans handlar det om att det blir ett väldigt spretigt erbjudande.
Så kunderna inte riktigt vet vad det är för någonting man står för.
Så då blir man irrelevant på det sättet.
Så jag tror att det det kokar ner till är att du måste kunna ha någon person som brinner för de kategorierna som du faktiskt säljer.
Så att du kan ha någon typ av edge mot övriga aktörer.
Så du kan presentera produkterna på något bra sätt.
Du kan göra dig till en branschspecialist som kunderna känner sig trygg med på något sätt.
Så att vi har ju verkligen börjat skala bort massa saker nu med leksaker och alla möjliga sådana saker som vi ändå kunnat få ta på förut.
Så att nu nischar vi oss ännu mer och fokuserar på det också.
Det friar ju manntimmar helt klart också.
Så jag tror att det är där det handlar om att du måste ha bra kategorichäfer eller produktchefer som driver de kategorierna.
De behöver inte älska allting men de måste vara passionerade och förstå marknaden och förstå vad det är för någonting de säljer.
Så att de kan paketera det på ett sätt så att kunderna faktiskt köper det.
Det är väl en diffus gränsdragning med den enda av en gränsdragning.
Jag tycker att det är rimligt.
När folk inom företaget inte längre brinner för produkten då är den irrelevant helt enkelt.
Det är väl ganska rimligt.
Ett företag som säljer vitvaror kan ni bara sälja i Sverige?
Blir logistiken för krånglig när man går utomlands?
Nej absolut inte.
Det går att sälja runtom i Norden och Europa också skulle jag säga.
Det finns lite olika hinder.
Jag skulle inte säga att logistiken i sig är ett hinder.
Det finns väldigt tunga saker som man skickar så man måste hålla koll på fraktkostnader framför allt till Nordnorge och sådana saker.
Vi gjorde det här på 30.se och vi har flera branschkollegier inom BOG som säljer runtom i hela världen.
Det som kanske är en sak som vi behöver ta hänsyn till mer och mer är att de leverantörerna som vi jobbar med de har specifika modeller som säljs på olika typer av marknader.
Man kan inte bara sälja svenska vitvaror i Tyskland till exempel utan det är ett helt eget sortiment som man får access till för att kunna sälja på de marknaderna.
Det är lite sådana där saker som man behöver ta ställning till istället.
Men det är fullt möjligt.
Det är jättemånga som gör så.
Men säljer ni utomlands?
Vi gör lite i startgrupparna för att göra det nu.
Men kan man göra det från ett svenskt lager?
Blir inte fraktkostnaden så pass bizarr att ni inte kan konkurrera mot ett lokalt bolag?
Nej, det skulle jag inte säga.
Det går att göra smarta saker också med mellanlandning på hubbar och sådant där.
Du kan konsolidera varorna på antingen spriditörernas terminaler eller i en egen hubb.
Sen är det lite olika upp till olika länder.
Norge kan vara lite dyrt.
Danmark är rätt okej.
Finland är också rätt okej.
Det gäller att hålla koll och göra hemläxande bara så är det inga problem.
Jag har lite förspänt också i och med att jag jobbar i en stor koncern med bolag som drivs i Finland, Norge, Danmark, Tyskland och Japan.
Där har vi all kunskap in house.
Man kan fråga vem som helst och förstå och lära sig hur man ska göra.
Det blir inte för att trasha caset, men det som var Hemmis stora grej, eller vitvaruexperten, era grej var att kunna erbjuda service och montering.
Att vara väldigt snabb och inte jobba med att ta produkter till er lager och sen skicka ut utan att faktiskt ha det hemma.
Nu sa du att det finns lite smarta lösningar utomlands.
Man kan ta det till en hubb.
Blir inte det emot er eget case?
Du har ju riktigt spot on.
Vi behöver ta oss ut på de här marknaderna och testa och se vad det är för någonting som flyger och inte flyger.
När det gör så finns vibjudna hela vägen.
Det är det vi måste bygga.
Så ni bygger inte en kopia av er egen business i till exempel Danmark.
Det är inte så att ni redan har satt upp ett serviceavtal med en massa service-tekniker.
Man testar och börjar med att skicka dit och se om marknaden finns.
Sen löser man lokala.
Vad intressant hur man sätter igång.
Det ska bli spännande att se.
Jag tycker alltid att det där är lite knepigt när man har en affär som är den riktiga affären.
Man kan lika gärna testa detta men så blir det inte exakt samma affär.
Det blir en annan affär som man inte riktigt är gjord för.
Var det något ni tänkte på i början eller var det mer att vi kan lika gärna sätta upp en hemsida i Danmark och se vad som händer?
När vi börjar planera den här satsningen eller?
Eller är tanken att ni om tio år verkligen ska ha fem, tio, femton länder till där ni ska ha liknande som ni har i Sverige?
Oj, det finns ingen sådan tioårsplan.
Just nu utan nu är det en uttalad strategi att gå Nordic som det heter.
Det är flera bolag inom BOG som gör det.
Vi hjälps åt helt enkelt att se till att det här kommer bli en bra lösning.
Så den sitter inte på en tioårsplan.
Det är ju längre än vad bolaget har funnits för att lämna sig så jag vågar inte planera så långt.
Men absolut ska vi kunna ha riktigt vassa konkurrenskraftiga inbröden i alla marknader som vi handlar på.
Definitivt.
Snabba leveranser inte minst.
Du säger att ni har funnits i tio år.
Kan du bli lite...
Du säger också att det är ett volume game så man måste upp i omsättning.
Absolut.
Men det är inte alla som kommer upp i omsättning på det här sättet på 8 år.
Då blir det 8 år då.
Så det är ju en rätt snabb tillväxt.
Vad är de svåraste grejerna som har uppstått under den här perioden när det gäller att hantera den här volymen av ordrar och produkter och människor.
Vad har varit knepigast i tillväxten?
Knepigast i tillväxten är väl...
Man vill ju gärna lägga mer saker och ting i lager och det gäller ju verkligen att balansera det mot likviditeten.
Och sen såklart allting som händer i världen.
Det är ganska extrema tider som vi har fått uppleva här med pandemier och störda leveranskedjor och inflationer och räntechocker och elkocker och allt möjligt.
Så det är ju inte ett normalt tid att bygga bolag på skulle jag säga.
Men det är många sådana där saker som har fått spela in såklart men där man har behövt anpassa sig extremt snabbt kring hur man förändrar affären.
I grund och botten så är det ju ganska enkelt ska man inte säga men det finns ju tre saker som man måste fokusera på.
Antingen så vill man bygga omsättning eller så vill man bygga vinst eller så måste man hålla likviditet och försöka sälja ner lager och hantera det.
De där tre måste man hela tiden ha i bakhuvudet och ha en tydlig prioriteringsordning kring för att veta hur man ska bygga sin strategi.
Den prioriteringsordningen har ju ändrats flera gånger om under alla de här åren så då gäller det att styra skutan åt något annat håll.
Så jag tror att det egentligen är det som är det viktigaste.
Och det är svårt att säga.
Man är ju så himla mycket uppe i allting hela tiden.
Det är ju så att du också är när du bygger ditt bolag.
Vad har du haft mest huvudvärk kring?
Vad är det du har legat vaken på på nätterna?
Bra fråga.
Jag tror allt att vi har köpt in för mycket till Black Friday.
Det kan vara någon försäljningsdipp under en vecka som man inte riktigt kan härleda till någonting speciellt.
Och sen plötsligt så bara rätta den upp sig i veckan efter utan att man har hittat en förklaring.
Sådana där saker tycker jag är irriterande.
Jag är ganska analytisk och försöker hitta svar på allting så att man kan lära sig från det.
Så det finns ingen stor process egentligen.
Ingen stor fas i det här som har spelat en större roll.
Jag kan ändå tycka det är lite charmigt.
När man omsätter 10 miljoner har man huvudvärken att man har köpt in lite för mycket i lager.
Och när man omsätter 100 miljoner så är det att man har köpt in lite för mycket i lager.
Och när man omsätter 250 miljoner så är det att man har köpt in lite för mycket felvara i lager.
Samma jävla huvudvärk följer med.
Det är som att någon borde hitta ett bra system för det där.
Exakt, exakt.
Jag ska släppa er där Björn.
Jag är jättetacksam för att du ville vara med här.
Det är väldigt spännande att få prata med någon som inte säljer trendiga varor med 70% i marginal utan någon som faktiskt får jobba på finlivet lite grann.
Jag tror att det är nyttigt för alla att förstå att man faktiskt kan driva som business.
Jag tror att vi alla har mycket att lära av det.
Även stort tack Joel, det var superkul att vara med.
Tack så mycket.
Jag ska bara säga, det är något som visslar i bakgrunden, hör jag lite grann.
Har du någon fläkt på eller liknande?
Nej?
Nej, det är inget sånt.
Är det hela tiden eller?
Tycker jag hör det ibland, det blir såhär...
Jaha, okej.
Min fru har en fågel, det kan vara den, men dörren ska vara stängda.